the Infinity Gauntlet is one of the
strongest weapons in the Marvel Universe
and in Avengers infinity war we watched
Thanos the mad Titan collect all of the
Infinity stones placed them in the
Infinity Gauntlet and with the snap of
his fingers wipe away half of the
population of the universe from
existence and then in Avengers in game
we watched professor Hulk used the
Infinity Gauntlet and Infinity stones
yet again to bring everybody back with
the snap of his fingers and then of
course with the snap of Iron Man's
fingers he eliminated Thanos and his
entire army there's no arguing that this
is one of the strongest weapons ever
created in any superhero universe but
with phase four phase 5 and the future
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe come in
could a new weapon be introduced that
could pose a bigger threat than the
Infinity Gauntlet what's up everyone
it's Warren and in this video I'm going
to talk about five weapons that could be
introduced in phase four phase five and
other future phases of the MCU that
could pose an even bigger threat than
the Infinity Gauntlet you see the
Infinity Gauntlet is quite arguably the
most powerful weapon in the entire
universe but it does require the
Infinity stones the gauntlet on its own
can't really do anything and there are
many weapons out there in the Marvel
Universe that on their own can do some
major major damage damage equaling what
the Infinity Gauntlet can do with all of
the Infinity stones so let's talk about
what these weapons are but a quick
reminder to subscribe to my channel so
you can stay up to date on the MCU and
so you can enter my giveaway for a
chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4 all
you have to do to enter is be subscribed
to my channel leave a comment and like
the video coming in at number 5 on this
list of weapons that are just as strong
or stronger than the Infinity Gauntlet
is the black vortex the black vortex was
created by the celestial Godhead he
created it for a race called the
Viscardi the black vortex grants its
users that succumb to it vast cosmic
powers essentially giving them powers as
the Celestials have not only does the
black vortex grant cosmic powers but it
also heavily amplifies power somebody
might already have for somebody like fan
owes the black vortex could grant him
powers with seemingly no limits it would
grant him cosmic powers to not only
create life but to destroy life as well
it would grant him powers to create a
multiverse and even to warp reality
essentially it could give him the powers
that the Infinity got
gave him but just as the Infinity
Gauntlet could only be used one or two
times to do something as big as wiping
out half of the population of the
universe the black vortex also comes
with a price the power that is bestowed
upon the user by the black vortex is
usually too much to handle for a mere
mortal
the result is a corrupted heart and loss
of humanity however someone such as
Thanos and eternal what the deviant gene
could not only handle the power but
would be amplified by it and the black
vortex would essentially make Fantas a
god with no need to snap his fingers or
close his hand to use the power of the
Infinity Gauntlet with the Infinity
stones coming in at number four on the
list as the ultimate nullifier in Marvel
Comics the ultimate nullifier has been
described as the universe's most
devastating weapon and is known to be
the only weapon in the entire universe
capable of inspiring fear in the one and
only Galactus himself and trust me it
takes a lot to scare Galactus the
ultimate nullifier belongs to Galactus
himself but once upon a time in the
comics the Human Torch stole it from
Galactus Reed Richards then threatened
Galactus with the ultimate nullifier
making him run he fled away out of fear
of the ultimate nullifier the ultimate
nullifier has the ability to completely
eliminate any target the wielder chooses
just like the black vortex the ultimate
nullifier powers are stronger when used
by somebody who has vast amounts of
power at themselves in the hands of
somebody with an extremely powerful mind
the ultimate nullifier can destroy
entire timelines from beginning to end
it can even erase and paradoxically
recreate the entire infinite Marvel
multiverse in the hands of fan oohs he
could have done exactly what he wanted
to do with the Infinity Gauntlet without
the damage however he would have had to
been extremely focused because when used
if the users mind is not focused enough
the ultimate nullifier will destroy its
user but Fanus went from planet to
planet destroying half of the population
trying to balance the universe so I'm
sure his mind would be focused coming in
at number three on the list is the
Makran crystal the Makran crystal is
often referred to as the nexus of all
realities legends say that the Makran
crystals homeworld was the first planet
to form and is as old as time itself it
is said that the creators of the crystal
named it the end of all
that is inside the crystal is an entire
city and in this city no space and time
exists because no space and time exist
within the crystal at the center of the
city was a glowing energy sphere which
hosted a neutron galaxy the son of this
neutron galaxy was a nexus point of all
matter and antimatter of not only the
universe but of all different realities
and existence
if the crystal stasis field should be
destroyed it would essentially destroy
the entire universe the gravitational
forces of the crystal would extend into
the universe drawing everything into a
black hole causing the universe to
collapse however it is believed that the
power of the crystal can be harnessed
every million years when nine galaxies
enter a certain alignment the crystal
opens up a gateway to what legends say
is absolute power essentially granting
the user the power to do anything his or
her mind could imagine
so although not a very practical or
easily accessible weapon it is one of
vast cosmic power that could change the
universe coming in at number two on the
list is the Cosmic Cube the Cosmic Cube
is extremely similar to the Infinity
Gauntlet in the sense that the Cosmic
Cube can essentially do anything on its
own that the Infinity Gauntlet can do
with all six Infinity stones the Cosmic
Cube can essentially do anything and
everything it's so powerful that it can
do whatever the user wishes it to do it
can create galaxies worlds it can
destroy worlds it can rewrite reality or
change the history of anyone or anything
black panther once used it to create
entire worlds and the Red Skull once
used it to create a new reality and
Thanos himself has even gotten his hands
on one at one point time in the comics
and he used the Cosmic Cube to do
exactly what he did with the Infinity
Gauntlet in the Infinity Gauntlet saga
he became the Supreme Being of the
universe he wills the cube to make him a
part of everything in the universe and
therefore puts him in control of
everything in the universe sadly for
Thanos much like when he became the
universe and the Infinity Gauntlet saga
using the Infinity Gauntlet this was
short-lived the superhero Marvel strips
him of his power by destroying the
Cosmic Cube so the cube basically does
everything the Infinity Gauntlet does
however it doesn't require six Infinity
stones there are some caches to the
cosmic cubes though that's right there
are more
one and they can essentially evolve into
sentient beans and these beans take on
the personality of people who have
wielded the cube in the past so if
Thanos and Red Skull wield the same cube
that ends up evolving into a sentient
being that sentient being is probably
not going to be very good
another catch is that the cube requires
extreme amounts of concentration and
whoever uses the Cosmic Cube is at great
risk not only is the user at risk but
everybody around the user is at risk as
well because if the users thoughts trade
just a tiny bit the entire planet that
the users on could be destroyed
so it's the typical saying with great
power comes great responsibility and
coming in at number one on the list is
the heart of the universe nothing and I
mean nothing except for perhaps the one
above all in the Marvel Universe is
stronger than the heart of the universe
not even the Infinity Gauntlet if
somebody willed the power of the heart
of the universe they become the
universe's Supreme Being at one point in
time in an alternate universe Thanos
wields the power of the heart of the
universe and when he becomes the Supreme
Being the universe allows him to learn
that the universe is flawed and is going
to end soon and not even the power of
the heart of the universe can fix it The
Living Tribunal gathers together a group
of the most powerful cosmic beings
eternity infinity death Galactus and the
Celestials to stop Thanos and these most
powerful cosmic beings despite being
omnipotent cannot stop Thanos the heart
of the universe had not only made Thanos
more powerful than these cosmic beings
just like he was when he had the
Infinity Gauntlet but it had actually
made him become one with everyone and
everything even the Living Tribunal
himself had become no more than a part
of Thanos Thanos would go on to absorb
all of the cosmic beings into himself
and in doing so he absorbed the entire
universe the only reason the universe
was restored was because Adam warlock
was outside the space-time continuum at
the time he finds Thanos and convinces
him to sacrifice himself and restore the
universe which he does so the heart of
the universe grants you the power to
become the universe which is something
that the Infinity Gauntlet and the
Cosmic Cube can only do to a certain
extent
but the heart of the universe its
absorbed into the person you can't take
away the power but when Thanos had the
Infinity Gauntlet and became the
universe his power was taken away by
nebula taking away the Infinity got one
from him and when he became the universe
with the Cosmic Cube that power was
taken away from him by Marvel who
smashed the cube so could the heart of
the universe be in the future of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe or could any
other one of these weapons be coming to
the MCU as well the Infinity Gauntlet is
definitely a hard weapon to top with all
the Infinity stones but as you can see
there are other weapons that are just as
strong if not stronger than the Infinity
Gotland so let me know what you think
about this list of Marvel's most
powerful weapons and let me know which
one you would like to see enter the MCU
leave all your thoughts in the comments
down below also don't forget to leave a
like if you enjoyed this video and don't
forget to subscribe if you'd like to see
more videos like this and if you'd like
to stay updated on everything relating
to the MCU also if you'd like a chance
to win an Xbox one or a ps4 all you have
to do is be subscribed to my channel
leave a like and a comment down below
I'll be picking a new winner at five
hundred and fifty thousand subscribers
you can follow me on Instagram and
Twitter for more giveaways as well and
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof